carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
les damos la bienvenida a este carrusel
de las artes especial desde la ciudad de
marsella en el sur de francia aquí a
orillas del mediterráneo vamos a
descubrir la efervescencia de la
creación del circo un arte que ha echado
raíces en esta región francesa
[Música]
estamos al marsella una de las capitales
del circo contemporáneo ciudad de
residencia y de creación para numerosos
artistas y sede de la bienal de circo
este año limitada por causa de crisis
sanitaria acrobacia danza equilibrismo
poesía descubriremos los espectáculos
concebidos para la bienal del circo de
marsella algunos firmados por mujeres
artistas y en nuestra crónica musical
conversaremos con una banda nativa de
estas tierras provenzales los delirantes
de luxe moustache quienes han
conquistado los escenarios físicos y
virtuales
[Música]
marsella y la región de la costa azul
francesa se han convertido en los
últimos años en un territorio para la
creación y el desarrollo de las artes
del circo numerosos artistas y compañías
se han establecido aquí convirtiendo a
la región en un polo importante y
reconocido en el mundo entero la ciudad
de marsella inscribió su nombre en la
galaxia del circo mundial gracias a la
fundación del centro de investigación
europeo de las artes del circo y de la
compañía de circo contemporáneo arca dos
que funcionan en esta ciudad en 2015 se
creó además la bienal del circo que
apoya y muestra el trabajo de nuevos
artistas venidos del mundo entero
[Música]
marsella está hecha para el circo desde
el principio quisimos trabajar aquí nos
pareció una evidencia ambos comparten
una dimensión popular el circo es un
arte de simplicidad y de expresión y
rápidamente vimos el potencial de la
ciudad para crear aquí un polo de
desarrollo
de creación hemos podido llevar a cabo
muchos programas culturales no solo con
los artistas sino también con los
diferentes barrios de la ciudad y con
todo tipo de público ha sido un
compromiso ciudadano esto nos llevó
luego a crear un gran festival del circo
que nos permitiera desarrollar nuevos
espectáculos y mostrarlos cada
espectáculo necesita dos años de
preparación pero aquí tenemos el
conocimiento y las estructuras para
hacerlo y lo mejor de todo es que ha
sido un éxito el primer año tuvimos 95
mil espectadores así que a pesar de
lakovic teníamos que hacer esta cuarta
bienal no podíamos anular las daño y les
vaques chou
la bienal del circo de marsella en 2021
no permitió recibir al público debido a
la crisis sanitaria sin embargo los
espectáculos se mostraron a los
profesionales y representantes de
festivales una etapa crucial para los
artistas en opinión de la cofundadora de
la bienal la brasileña raquel raq de
andrade fue así un periodo 20 facebook
2h ha sido un periodo extremadamente
complicado para los artistas y lo sigue
siendo nadie se imaginó nunca que esta
crisis sería tan violenta en especial
para el mundo de las artes escénicas
todos los espectáculos fueron anulados
las giras las nuevas producciones los
teatros siguen cerrados todo fue
paralizado de la noche a la mañana y sin
que se sepa cuándo volveremos a ver al
público la situación es muy delicada
para algunas compañías con las que
trabajamos que quizás no sobreviven a
esta crisis es una realidad muy triste
inicios a realidad que muchos difícil
muchas dudas para ellos
[Música]
en 2021 la bienal de marsella es una
invitación especial ayudan mucho a un
artista al que le gusta desafiar la
gravedad su pieza sólo y quitumbe el que
se cae se compone de una plataforma
giratoria en la que seis personas tratan
de mantenerse de pie un thriller
circense en extraña sintonía con el
torbellino de la vida moderna
estoy en explorer y mi trabajo me gusta
explorar la interacción del ser humano
con los diferentes fenómenos físicos
como la velocidad la fuerza centrífuga
el equilibrio el desequilibrio todos los
aparatos que usamos en el circo están
resumidos en esta plataforma sobre la
cual se encuentra este grupo humano que
tratan de no caer ciencia tenía de book
[Música]
y si este año de hoy en día tratar de
mantenerse de pie es una temática
pertinente y en resonancia con lo que
estamos viviendo y la verdad es que no
todas las épocas generan tanta empatía
por el vértigo si lo consideramos como
la pérdida de referencias o de un suelo
firme entonces si estamos en un momento
de cambio de paradigmas es normal que
sintamos empatía por lo vertiginosa tipo
de gestión
[Música]
desde que era niño lo que más me ha
atraído del circo es que los artistas
abordan otras dimensiones del espacio y
yo creo que esta es una época para
reflexionar sobre el espacio que
ocupamos en el planeta el circo tiene
algo que decir en este momento en el que
es vital que pensemos en nuestro medio
ambiente donde son red ecológicos somos
historia en alma
[Música]
no
entre las propuestas de mujeres autoras
en 2021 encontramos la primera versión
en circo del lago de los cisnes' escrito
por flojos cayón quien es también
compositor a la pieza para tres hombres
y dos mujeres cisnes mezcla circo y
ballet algo que flojo es cayón llama
circo coreográfico y de objeto de pago
lo que hice fue reescribir algunos temas
de la partitura original del lago de los
cisnes' de tchaikovsky las historias de
príncipes y de princesas no es lo que
más me llama la atención más bien quise
abordar el tema de la ilusión amorosa a
veces conocemos a alguien comenzamos una
relación pensando saber quién es y que
las cosas no van a cambiar pero tiempo
después descubrimos facetas
completamente distintas nos damos cuenta
entonces que las relaciones pueden ser
ambiguas entonces
sus únicos quien en esta pieza use
códigos que se encuentran tanto en el
ballet como en el circo en los dos
pueden haber dúos o los tríos y eso me
hizo pensar que la vida y el amor pueden
ser así también la relación amorosa a
veces es multiforme y a veces estamos en
pareja puede ser un hombre y una mujer
dos hombres dos mujeres a lo largo de la
vida vivimos momentos en pareja en tríos
relaciones efímeras o largas a veces
queremos estar solos porque no pau para
juegos debido a una solicitud de poco
acto
otro estreno lleno de poesía y danza la
pieza éter lleva al espectador entre
cielo y tierra dos bailarinas se
ejecutan una danza enigmática atracción
rechazo desconfianza una paleta de
emociones se descubren a través del
cuerpo y la acrobacia su autora fan y
soriano
es un espectáculo de circo para dos
jóvenes mujeres que tiene como centro el
movimiento ellas se descubren y bailan
en un paisaje casi lunar aunque hay
momentos acuáticos también es una danza
en la que se conocen se desprecian
juegan no hay historia sino un llamado a
incluir las emociones entre dos personas
aunque pareciera que bailan todo gira en
torno al movimiento y al cuerpo yo no
soy bailarina sino artista de circo pero
me interesa mucho explorar la suavidad
del cuerpo y la dramaturgia que surge
del movimiento le pido a mis artistas
que busquen la armonía y la fluidez que
hay en la acrobacia propia del siglo
[Música]
les proponemos ahora en nuestro programa
descubrir a una banda que está teniendo
un éxito rotundo en toda francia son los
gusta yo un grupo musical que nació en
estas tierras provenzales y nuestra
compañera natalia olivares los conoció
aquí en marsella
y justo aquí en esta región de marsella
de nexo 2 cerquita de aquí nació la
banda de luxe estas seis integrantes
seis energías
músicos juntos forman una bola de
energía tenemos la suerte de tener a dos
de ellos lee boyd y pp
[Música]
cada día
para mí
[Música]
lo mejor de luxe bigote es que todos
somos del mundo super diferentes y nos
complementamos todos tenemos nuestro
papel en la banda y musicalmente todos
aportamos nos hemos construido juntos yo
no sería el mismo si no hubiera conocido
a los chicos y a lily boy nos creamos
juntos y construimos juntos una
verdadera victoria
[Música]
el último éxito es twenty tuenti con un
clip lleno de colores que cuenta esa
canción ascenso a su equipo es una
canción que habla de este año que fue
duro para nosotros habla de esos aires
de apocalipsis y de fin del mundo que
vivimos también quisimos hablar de
nuestra relación de grupo que es como
una pareja de seis personas habla de
cómo cuando las cosas están mal por
fuera lo importante es lo que sucede por
dentro lo importante es que como grupo
todo funciona
[Música]
en la piel del sylvester stallone del
último clip cómo se siente
cecilio hay que decir eso es lo bueno
del deporte nos refuerza la autoestima
hay que hacer deporte
amigos
[Música]
y todos los chicos de la banda lleva
bigote porque cualquier bigote y no la
barba
es la marca identidad con la que nació
nuestra banda nosotros empezamos a tocar
en la calle y en algún momento pensamos
en nuestra imagen y nos dejamos crecer
los bigotes finalmente se quedó así y
ahora el bigote está en todas partes en
nuestras redes sociales en nuestros
productos en nuestros discos excesos y
casos de éxito muchas gracias de louis
por haber estado con nosotros chau
mcshane y gracias por haber estado en
carrusel de las artes gracias natal y
olivares y vamos a despedir este
programa carrusel de las artes especial
desde marsella justamente con un tema de
los de luxor moustache muchísimas
gracias por haber estado con nosotros
cuídense mucho y hasta la próxima
[Música]
no